[Musique]
J'ai une intervention chirurgicale d'urgence à effectuer à
Baltimore Je volerai où que j'arrive
ce soir pour l'obtenir demain matin pouvez-
vous m'aider monsieur Je pense que nous pourrions avoir le
même problème J'ai une idée alors quelle est
la hâte que je suis  se marier demain
Oh félicitations non non c'est nous ne venons pas de
passer ce qui a pris votre
conférence médicale dans l'Idaho nous entrons dans ce sujet vous
n'avez pas expliqué les questions
mon téléphone n'a pas de signal et nous sommes assez
haut sur la montagne si nous restons ici,
nous dirons que si nous quittons certains secours,
ils sont moins susceptibles de nous trouver, regarde, je
ne veux pas mourir ici parce que tu es
trop peur de prendre un risque
la fille de quelqu'un force le pilote dans un avion fleuri
personne ne sait où nous sommes nous sommes tous nous
avons moi et toi
nous pouvons passer trois semaines jusqu'à trois
jours sans eau et trois heures
sans téléphones portables
nous pourrions mourir ensemble  Je ne te connais même pas,
je vais mourir à la maison aujourd'hui
[Musique]